承认我克我爸，所以我要离得远一点，姑娘，你们所有的姐妹一定要学会这一招，这一招特别好使，谁骂我我承认，你骂我说我爸是被我气的是吧，我承认，所以我要少跟他见面，少气他，我少克他，我就是克我爸爸，就是吵。我想咨询你的事情是关于父母和原生家庭的事情，我先介绍一下我自己，我结婚4年了，有一个女儿，这两岁半，我跟我老公感情都很好，我父母从小都是控制型的父母，我父母那边的娘家还有一个弟弟，就是这个事情，是前几天发生的一个事情，因为我弟弟现在就是有什么事情，弟弟做了什么不满意的事情，娘家的父母都会找到我，说是因为我挑唆的我弟弟，然后让我弟弟现在不听话也好，怎么样也好，我举个例子，前几天的时候，我弟弟谈了一个女朋友，因为他谈的是异地的，从异地来我们这边，我父母他们是属于那种在我看来心气比较高，然后有点白莲花，我真的就是这样说，他从外地来，然后我弟弟前几天晚上就给我打电话，就说明天一块儿吃个饭，和我爸和我妈，还有他女朋友，我说可以，等到第二天了，我就问我弟弟，我说什么时候。
吃饭，因为我带着孩子，我害怕再不方便，或者再耽误时间，耽误太久，然后他们等着我呢，然后我弟就说下午过了一会儿呢，然后我弟弟给我打电话说改到中午吃饭了，我说哦，行，我都有谁在哪里，饭店在哪里？我弟就跟我说饭店到现在都没定，他说爸爸和妈妈不去了，就刚你和我还有他女朋友。我说行，那我订个饭店吧。然后吃完了饭，我就问他这个小女孩，我说你什么时候走，这个小女孩儿就说当天下午就走六七点的高铁，我说那正好吃饭的地点，离那个她坐高铁的高铁站大约是开车得一个半小时，我说今天我开车了，要不然我去送你吧，我是好心，然后我就去送了他，送了他下了高速，离我家还有半个来小时的路程，我妈就给我打电话，就是说很难听的话，接着就说我，他说你到哪了，我说我刚下高速，他就说我太能了，我说我怎么了，我说你这样说我，然后我妈就说不用管你怎么了，我跟你解释不了，因为你不是个人人，现在你主要问的是跟家里面的人人的相处，那你现在得告诉我，你现在情况怎么样，自己收入怎么样，跟你的对象怎么样，你自己的小家庭经营的怎么样，但凡是小家庭，如果经营的很好的话，跟原生的家庭，那就看爸。
说吧，妈妈小的时候对你怎么样，在你读书的过程当中，对你支撑了多少，托举了多少，咱们该回报就回报，如果说他们对你没有什么托举，没有什么支撑，咱们该少来往就少来往。从结了婚之后，我就一直没有工作，我今年27，女儿是两岁半，你跟你老公感情咋样？我跟我老公感情很好，那你是读书读到什么学历？我读书读到本科，爸妈对你的托举还是很好的，能让你读到本科。我有一句话，我应该这么形容我爸妈，就是他们对我的爱是真的，但是他们每一次带给我的心理伤害也是真的。那我问你，你在结婚之前干过什么工作？我在结婚之前一直是幼师，嗯，现在孩子两岁多了，你是计划还出去工作吗？因为是这样，我老公是自己干的个体，我在给我老公的公司里面，家里面做会计，那你老公干这个个体大概一年的盈利是多少啊，能挣多少钱呀，大约是200个哦，能挣200多万，那相当厉害了，那你现在手上有多少存款呀，我手上是不是，那你和你娘家的关系，现在主要的矛盾是集中在你对弟弟的态度，你爸妈不满意，或者说你对弟弟帮衬少了你爸妈。
满意是集中在这里吗？不光这里是从结完婚，我手里的这些钱是结婚之前我是一分存款都没，就是有存款，但是我一个W都存不到，我结婚之前就是我爸和我妈给我10万块钱的陪嫁钱，结完婚的第三天我就把这个陪嫁钱还给我爸了，也就是说相当于我结婚四年了，我也不知道那个陪嫁的10万块钱的银行卡密码是什么，他们也从来没有再说是给过我，我也不需要这10万块钱，我说真心话，我也没有图过他们一毛钱，但是就是在今年4月多份的时候，其实矛盾点就有了，因为我从结完婚到现在，可以说是我手里所有的钱都是公公和我，我老公给我的，我爸和我妈一直在惦记我手里的钱，从结完婚的第一年，我爸张口就跟我老公借60万，用来他还贷款，这是第一年，第二年和第三年是我一直在偷偷的把我手里的存款转给我爸和我妈，今年是我结婚的第4年嘛，就相当于是第一年我老公帮我爸和我妈还的贷款，第二年和第三年是我等到今年是第4年，今年他们还贷款我没有给，他们就开始说我是白眼狼，那我问你，你老公帮你爸爸还60万贷款这个事儿后来你爸爸还。
那么还给你老公了吗？还给我老公了，你帮他们还贷款，那个钱他们还给你了吗？都还给我了，借钱的时候说还贷款的时候说的是一个周之内就会给我，他因为觉着我老公可能不是很干儿，他就贷款下来了，接着就给我老公了，但是第二年和第三年的钱是我和他们一要，我说我老公厂里有什么事儿，有点发不下来工资了，以这个名义他才给我的，你老公确实对你不错，哦，对呀，你爸妈在你结婚也就一年多的时间，张口借60万，你老公都愿意借哦，我感觉是你老公确实对你不错，那你就好好跟你老公关起门来过日子呀，然后你爸妈那头，其实我感觉是，是不是你在他们面前透露了你老公的实力，说一年能挣200万啊，怎么怎么地的，让他们觉得从你这儿挣钱，你看你一年都只能挣200万，我就借个60万，我借一下怎么了？你有的时候我跟你说啊，哪怕是亲爹亲妈，你也要遏制自己在她面前去炫耀的这样一个冲动。还有一件什么事情，重点是我爸和我妈和我老公和我公公和婆婆那边闹的根本不愉快，就是我们结完婚的第二天，我妈就因为我老公带来的东西少，我们这边叫回嘛，就因为带来的东西少，把我老公骂了，然后给我公公打个电话，说的难听的。
他们关系根本不好，我老公借给我爸和我妈交这个钱，纯粹就是因为我老公就直接跟我说了，害怕我在中间受难，关系不好正合适啊，关系好才怕以后麻烦多呢。姑娘，你看事情一定要看到这件事情的对你有利的地方，正因为你的爸爸妈妈把你老公骂一通，把你公公婆婆骂一通，正好以后少来往，正好以后经济上少牵扯。他在问你借的时候，你说你都把人骂成那样了，你还管人借钱，人怎么可能借给你呢？一句话就搪塞回去了。对我之前的时候这些话我不好意思说，我总觉得是自己的亲生父母驳了他们的面子说这些话，但是今年就是因为我们没借给他钱，然后他说我是白眼狼，说就说呗，是就是呗，他们觉得我老公的原生家庭，我公公和我婆婆是农村人，他们总觉着他们不上面子，不上档次，就觉得我公公和我婆婆办事上不了台面，是呗，承认以后你爸妈说什么都承认，说你白眼狼，承认说你公婆上不了台面，承认说你老公对他不尊敬，承认都承认，这样太少来往。还有一点是什么呢？我爸的身体不是很好，但是我爸的身体不好是因为他小的时候，在没有我和我弟的时候，他身体就不是很好，然后我妈总是拿我爸身体不好来PV我。
说你爸身体不好，就是让你气的，你看你这么多年，你就没让你爸省么心，怎么怎么样，就说这种话，承认我克我爸，所以我要离得远一点，姑娘，你们所有的姐妹一定要学会这一招，这一招特别好使，谁骂我我承认你骂我，说我爸是被我气的是吧，我承认，所以我要少跟他见面，少气他，我少克他，我就是克我爸的，就是承认他骂你白眼狼，承认我就是白眼狼，他骂你怎么怎么地的啊，有了那个老公了之后，就忘了娘了，承认我就是你一旦承认了之后，你发现，哦，这关系太好处了，太好处了，我都承认啊，我又克你，我又气你，我又白眼狼，你天天找我干什么，没必要找我呀，我妈现在就是，她总是骂我的时候，就是什么话她都能说的出来，就是这两天骂我骂的就是把我之前谈的对象也说出来，之前谈的对象她说出来的那个话，我都无法相信这是一个妈妈对自己的女儿说的话，她说每一次我们一有点什么矛盾点，我妈就是从头捋一遍，从我刚出生，她对我的不满也好，怎么怎么样也好，她生活多难也好，怎么怎么样也好，就都和我说出来，解决不了当下的矛盾，然后总是把之前的所有的矛盾点全拉出来过一遍，每一次吵架都是这样子。我现在想问龙菲姐的事情就是我该怎么样。
因为我和我爸和我妈生活在一个吃八线的小城里，我们的家也挨的不是很远，我该怎么样，就是远离他们，真正能远离的话，就是在心里完全接纳，在心里完全摆烂。他们说我白眼狼，我承认，他们说我克他们，我承认，他们说什么事都是我气的，我承认，我都承认，我都认账，你说我跟我前男友怎么怎么，我承认，只要我能够认准这个世界上谁在真正的对我好，谁在真正的心疼我，我全心全意的对待那些心疼我的对我好的人，不管别人怎么说，不管你爸妈说你公婆能不能上得了台面，你手上这50万的存款都是你老公和你公婆给你的，就凭这一点，对吧？他们是真心心疼你的人，你对那些真心对你好的人要付出同样的真心，然后关起门来过日子，你爸妈那一头的话，实话实说啊，我们换位思考一下，如果我的女儿嫁出去了，我在我女儿嫁出去的第一年，脚跟都没有站稳的时候，我就去问我的亲家借60万，这事儿打死我我也干不出来，因为我怕给女儿带来不好的影响，我怕嗯，婆家人难为我女儿或者瞧不起我女儿，所以这60万的话，我不可能管我女婿去借这60万，真的实话实说啊，当爹当妈的真心希望女儿在婆家过得好的话，不会上来。
才就问你老公去借这个钱的，你只能怎么样，我承认啊，是吧，你们不管骂我什么我都承认，那我没办法啊，但是我觉得就是逢年过节到他们过生日的时候，该给红包还是得给红包，客客气气的做就完事儿了啊，我老公现在上我妈那儿去还叫妈，我妈就是装听不见，你其实可以跟你老公松绑，你跟你老公怎么松绑吗？你就说我也是看到了我爸妈对你的这个不友好的这个态度，所以呢，以后你对我爸妈的态度的话，也不用顾及我，你不用觉得说我脸上没光，不用觉得说要让我感受到重视啊怎么的啊，我觉得就是人的尊重是相互的，如果他们不尊重你，你也没有必要叫他们，没有必要委屈自己，我要是么的话，我能跟老公这么说，我就是这样跟我老公说的，他这次就是他知道了这个事情，原来这个事情我都基本上不敢让他知道，因为我生怕关系再闹僵了，那天我实在开不了车了，然后我给我老公打电话，我老公接着就来了，来了之后他知道事情原委，就特别生气，他没想到就是说我爸和我妈竟然对我说这样的话，他说一个自己的亲生孩子都不包容的人，他能包容谁呀？就这样说我爸和我妈，然后我妈就这两天又开始说我和我老公每年去给他送年礼的时候，送的太晚了，都是29才给他送年。
礼，因为我老公他是自己干的哈，然后他得送礼啊什么的，所以难免不了得我们这边忙完，然后再去，他就说不重视他怎么怎么样的，说以后每一年送年礼，你和你老公第一个先上我们家来，什么意思啊，每一年送年底29才来，你是看不起谁呀，就这样说我是看不起啊，我就承认啊，以后就少来往啊，你其实心中就是一定要给自己松绑，一定要给自己那个枷锁松绑了，其实你无外乎就是怕你爸妈在外面败坏你的名声，说你不孝，所以你嫁给了国家了之后，对娘家人不好，如果你一旦接纳了呢，我就是不孝，我就是对我国家人好，我就是对我老公好，我就是对我爹妈不够好，一旦我心里接纳了这个人设呢，我还会怕他在外面去拜坏我的名声吗？能理解，很想听你一声，我心里就舒服了。我两天晚上没睡个好觉了，就是感觉自己被自己的亲爸亲妈这样说，感觉自己很呀。其实我跟你说，古时候像那种用孝道来绑架儿女的人更夸张，因为在古时候那样的生存环境，如果你被别人定义为一个不孝的孩子的话，那你可能是寸步难行的啊，当官没你的份，考公务员没你的份，当老师没你的份，你都生存不下去。但是确实并不是所有的父母都配做父母的，并不是所有的爹妈都做爹。
妈的，像古时候那样的制度的话，更是残害这些儿女，像现在这个社会环境下的话，还好很多，他就算在外面败坏你的名声的话，也不影响你的工作，不影响你挣钱，不影响你生存，不影响你跟你自己的同事之间的关系，完全不影响，因为大家都有感同身受，所有当过儿女的人都会有感同身受，并不是所有的父母都是真正爱孩子的，并不是所有的父母都觉得养孩子是无条件的托取孩子怎么怎么样，有些父母他生孩子出来的话，就是为了宣泄他心中的那些权利欲望，生孩子出来的话，就是有一个幼小的生命可以被他掌控，就是有一个幼小的生命可以让他去体会一个人的那个权利的那个感觉。真的，姐妹们，一旦我们接纳了，我就是不笑，你会发现啊，就谁也没有办法再拿孝道来绑架我了。好，我没有别的事情了，老跟你，我就是真的很想逃离我的原生家庭，逃离就逃离，你现在翅膀硬了，你现在自己跟婆家的关系又这么好，自己有了自己的孩子了啊，只是我希望你在你父母身上学到的东西是，你不要去这样对待你的孩子，我不会放心关起来过日子啊，好好珍惜那些真心待你的人，好好珍惜那些确实是心疼你对你好的人啊，好，谢谢你，你好，就这样。